oh hi have you ever dreamed of going
undercover and infiltrating a Hong Kong
organized crime gang slowly working your
way up through the ranks while knowing
that at any minute if your fellow gang
members were to find out that you were a
cop they would chop you up into
delicious sesame chicken me either I
have no tolerance for pain and no poker
face whatsoever but that's the great
thing about video games they let you
vicariously live this lifestyle from the
comfort and safety of your couch in
sleeping dogs available tuesday for the
pc xbox 360 and playstation 3 you play
wei shen an undercover cop embedded in a
street gang whose name i am not even
going to attempt to pronounce people are
already writing angry forum letters that
i mispronounced wei shen sleeping dogs
greatest strength is it's a story you
don't get to make any major decisions as
to what way Shen should do but the
linear story is gripping you watch him
interact with the cops and gang members
you see his loyalties tested you wonder
which way he's gonna go great writing
excellent voice acting all around
sleeping dogs is not a bad looking game
but it's graphics well they aren't
really that hot the city of Hong Kong is
a lot of fun to blaze around town in
when you hijack a fast car but if you
stop and look around it's all kind of
blase everything runs together there's
no incredible sights to admire that said
I really enjoyed driving around in the
rain with a Cantonese love song playing
on the cars radio there's two main modes
of combat martial arts and gunplay
ironically sleeping dogs becomes a lot
easier when the guys are shooting at you
versus when they're just trying to punch
you in the face I died many more times
in the martial arts battles than I did
when the assault rifles came out
Sleeping Dogs kinda likes to punish you
for having fun as a cop you lose
experience points if you hit parking
meters or run people over now yes okay
cops probably should not just go around
flattening citizens into scallion
pancakes but come on you try not doing
that in a Grand Theft Auto clones like
dangling a marshmallow in front of a
child and saying don't eat it there's
other polish issues that can make
sleeping dogs frustrating for example
depending on where you're standing the
button to hail a taxi is the same button
that violently rips the driver out of
the taxi and throws him out of the
asphalt the cars GPS system sucks it
doesn't know about some roads and tells
you the wrong places to go the device
hacking mini games are fun at first but
they don't change throughout the entire
game and become really repetitive so in
the end it's a pile of little things
like this that drag sleeping dogs down
on balance it's a fun game with
addictive bite-sized missions really
good story I liked it it just isn't
quite the game that it should be